yo tout le monde sait ce quiz jeunes
gens se retrouvent pour la troisième et
dernière vidéo sur you want the grudge
chinois ce dernier épisode a alors c'est
parti
c'est quoi cette photo sans déconner on
l'a vu dans chaque épisode un homme et
non mais quoi
oh c'est horrible c'est horrible auquel
ma rentrée va faire beau et chaud je
collecte est cité au nom mais qu enfin
screamer de la prince seconds rôles à la
ok j'avais oublié l'ambiance méga chelou
de the grudge ah oui toujours quand même
ça ça pourrait servir on sait jamais
c'est bien tu fais elle est elle fera
bon alors c'est parti
ah c'est vrai qu'à des histoires de
batterie et où je vous cache pas que ces
genres de jeux auxquels je ne joue
absolument pas entre chaque vidéo assez
bizarrement est ce qu'on mange chez les
petites petites nous y préparer là-bas
bien sûr
alors j'adore koweït ont fait le plein
en face des yeux qu a donc où faut-il
aller alors je propose qu'on y aille au
feeling quoi faire de manière bien
évidemment va devoir commencer sans faux
avant une cinématique mais qui s'était
sur l'écran pas un employé à une heure
pareille
bon je dois d'abord m'occuper de
l'électricité même les téléphones ne
marche plus je me demande qui c'était
ils sont naïfs à chaque fois en fait ces
gens-là heroes bon c'est déjà mieux
qu'anna esquiro aujourd'hui va être un
vrai héros alors déjà pour les trous
qu'il aura sur ces petites et ses
petites lumières alors bas à droite fin
et qui nous rassure bon voila voila ou
oui ok première attaque de type
pulmonaire vasculaires oh non mais
sérieux je suivrai attendait mais ça
c'est quoi ce bordel c'est un mal car
août c'est ce petit enfant qui en mode
pause mais non mais non mais je déteste
ça déteste ça je déteste j'étais
peut-être pas fini
c'est quoi ça là-bas watts il a bougé
bateau temps il ya un gros problème est
que ces mannequins déjà alors c'est ça
pour établir est restée bien sûr que oui
bim bam boum terminée et ben non
ah ok c'est la porte de [ __ ] je suis
en train de baver [ __ ] train de me
dire qu'ils jouent avec ce vote qu'un de
l'autre côté d'eux non non au nom elle
est la plus tard mais attendez ça fait
une minute
oh oh oh c'est bon à séduire fait penser
à bas du tout en fait il me faut une
pizza 1
ben voilà exactement ce qu'il nous
fallait quoi petit micro ondes [ __ ] je
savais qu'on aurait dû prendre les
pattes là du début je le savais mais
[ __ ] en fait quand j'ai peur je
tremble et ça me fait faire demi-tour
qua non mais c'est mon dada me
chatouiller le visage aussi un moment sa
[ __ ] ou quoi ah [ __ ] mais il ressemble
à un mannequin homme et non oui elle
fasse tout simplement parce qu'on va zy
tu peux pas seulement le fait que tu
veux y'a pas de problème
encore des toilettes logiquement elle
est pas là mais après la logique dans le
jeu allez allez elle est ok donc
quelqu'un qui a une vilaine gastro qui
fait ce bruit une pile à n'ont par
contre je laisse la porte ouverte se
plaît ben oui mais c'est quoi ces
toilettes des mesures de champ de force
invisible je suis pas rentré dedans non
ok c'est l'autre qui est passée qui a
réservé les toilettes c'est ça toi je
veux dire je travaille ici quand même un
peu de respect quoi ta merde quoi ait
des hommes c'est toujours un peu plus un
peu plus du diabolique que toi et tes
femmes on le voit notamment sur la sur
la cuma a tu t'es trompette toilettes
coquinot alors c'est pas tes cheveux
mais c'est quelqu'un qui avait des très
longs poils de base c'est joli ça le bon
voilà voilà
j'avais dit quoi c'est plus diabolique
qu'est ce que au même nom ici c'est oit
des hommes [ __ ] tu t'es trompé bordel
je vois des petits pieds au plus tard ça
serait alors plus avec vont être ici un
mois je vous parlais je suis désolé mais
ce non regardez comme je tremble mais ta
phut mais c'est une blague mais vous
avez vu le cercil fait [ __ ] il était
parti avec carlo sur pierre papon quoi
or votre chien quoi merde rebelles qui
assume plus du tout ces vidéos mais
qu'on fait ce sont des groupes issus de
quoi ils savent très bien que tu
trembles et lui demande de mettre le
curseur dans un seul grand comme ça quoi
le truc il est aussi grand que le haut
du début du menu mais non mais j'ai
tellement pressé je voulais prendre ma
pile là dans la salle où il ya micro oh
oh je les passais pas c'était vraiment
juste à temps mais c'est méga dur à
l'appui ses cheveux l as et ça c'est
pour ça qu'elle venait en fait un nom en
fait non on a ramassé un code pin
je pense qu'il faut ramasser tous les
codes pin le screamer de merde
la pile alcaline merci à l'homme qui
avait oublié sa pile aux toilettes elles
ouvrent à la porte
qu'est ce qu'on trouve derrière vieille
des échasses pour reparaître plus boîte
merci les gars c'est alors c'est par où
la soirée c'est par la hausse est trop
gentil salut les filles comment ça va on
est bien ici on est bien
oh mon dieu une autre partie du code pin
9 au nom elle est là voilà et la tension
est ce que ça vient du bras pas du tout
à fait juste là alors qu'est-ce qu'on
fait quelque côté hoba hoba hoba cause
droit droit droite c'est bouron la passe
tu me fait pas peur
ou devrais je dire tu fais pas bon on
est vraiment comique aujourd'hui mais
c'est ses mannequins là il m'inspire
beaucoup hein pas du tout chaud chaud
chaud chaud
il commence à manquer le petit enfant là
qui nous guide j'ai pas j'aimais bien au
moins il nous dit [ __ ] c'est horrible
il manque pas du tout en fait c'est pas
quelqu'un gribouillés sur les murs voici
une petite enfance
mais attends mais le mec c'est un
artiste quoi sans déconner fait des
tableaux volés enfin je sais pas à ça
s'ouvre 100 m pour moi ça à abbas était
pour lui en fait j'ai plus de crayon
bon alors débrouille tirage avait plus
qu'assez 1 alors est-ce que si moment de
se poser un petit peu regardez même une
cigarette quoi parfait attendait mais
tout s'explique avec cette cigarette
c'était pour ça qu'il fait juste des ses
fugues quatre paquets par jour forcément
à merde on a raté un papier il est où
ben oui les excuser moi oui oui vous vu
un petit bout de papier avec un chiffre
dessus et je chante un palestinien il
alcalines tu as même mon ventre ils ont
peu plus fou j'avais oublié à balayer
une seule que j'ai pas fait
excusez moi assez bien sa photocopie
note qu on l'a trop petit ou pas désolé
pour cette blague bulgare j'ai pas de
justificatifs
voilà à part que je suis en stress à
screamer sérieusement de prescrire un
arrêt cardiaque
hop là oui il est là il est sur la table
regarder a pas du tout c'est un cendrier
[ __ ] mais elle fait chier l'autre à
fumer ces quatre paquets à chaque fois
il est là et sur le canapé non c'est une
pile mais c'est vrai ça plus tard sa
coda trois chiffres on s'en fout et le
chiffre qu'on a déjà on sait où ils sont
en plus donc dès ses dix fois avec des
chiffres différents
tu l'auras ton [ __ ] de code bordel tu
as tout citer aussi intelligente que ce
mannequin quoi 2 voilà en plus au bout
de deuxième site avec bons chiffres
allemands nous attaquer je le sais voilà
qu'est ce qu'elle fait mais regardez
comme directeur de somnambules qui vient
se lever
à jouer s'il n'a pas pris la place d'un
match aller ouvrir ses dons à la porte
des gis cotiser plus et que ça j'ai
l'impression qu'on marche sur 22 km en
réalité on marche sur 22 m country times
elle marchait et dans le couloir babe à
l'essec pour ceux du jeu c'est une nuit
de travail difficiles farine la puce ne
pas entrer ce n'est pas une personne
autorisée
moi je pense que je suis autorisé
jusqu'à preuve du contraire et leur de
rétablir l'électricité et la vérité
puisque nous a filmés piqueur paytoo
sommes allés à attention je suis prêt à
pointer dans le cercle à hay al shoula
aux gens tant le petit bruit
attention screamer je vais avoir peur
oui alors je suis prêt tu prêt gauche
derrière
[ __ ] [ __ ] ce jeu d'état ce genre de
truc quoi ok maintenant c'est tous à
l'eau jusqu'à preuve du contraire j'ai
fait ce qu'il fallait
j'ai rétabli électricité un [ __ ] on a
plus de puits lâche moi une petite pile
te plaît on doit retourner à notre
boucle office la non mais c'est pas
possible tu ta il faudra un autre air de
country quoi et marchait seule dans le
noir est un film érotique qui
s'activaient à vatel you bon lire dessus
oui c'est une araignée ou une femme
humaine je ne sais pas quand je jouais
mon père mon père mon gars non je te
jure que si tu perds c'est la claque
attaques virtuelles au gauche gauche du
tarn et avaient souffert dans tous les
sens à ce quoi expliquer moi clairement
oui c'est ok on dirait que c'est un
combat des pays avec moi le casque petit
flash le flash qui nous met bien j'ai
plus de 100 jusqu'à se pose
aussi vraiment que j'allais en faire
exprès appuyé sur menu wii qu'est ce qui
se passe maintenant
oh [ __ ] non non non will elles sont
très belles et et pupilles à ton
maquillage rouge vraiment extra et ça si
les épisodes terminés niveau de
l'acheter on a un peu plus lâche que
d'habitude un mois ferme acquiesce de
tes proches dégueulasse comme l'album de
drogue c'était simple cd n'a pas
exactement quand même temps et voilà les
gens c'est déjà la fin de cette série
sur the grudge [ __ ] qu'est ce que
c'était flippant bordel j'espère que ça
vous a plus ce cas n'hésitez pas aimé la
vidéo ça me fera plaisir pour se
retrouve très vite dans une nouvelle
vidéo a et pas dans une nouvelle
chorégraphie de danse à je suis craquer
les pôles chat au monde glisse
[Musique]